हेलो एवरीवन एंड फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल वेरी गुड
इवनिंग टू ऑल। तो प्लीज सबसे पहले मुझे यह
बताइए सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है। आई
एम ऑडिबल एवरीवन।
ओके थैंक यू। अगर आप सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई
दे रही है तो। तो 2 मिनट के लिए वेट करते
हैं। बाकी स्टूडेंट्स को आने देते हैं। तब
तक के लिए अगर कोई मेरी प्रीवियस क्लास का
स्टूडेंट है और प्रीवियस क्लास से रिलेटेड
कोई डाउट है आप लोगों को तो आप लोग मुझसे
पूछ सकते हो। तब तक के लिए बाकी जो
स्टूडेंट नहीं आते उनका वेट करते हैं। पर
आप मुझसे कोई भी डाउट पूछ सकते हो
स्टूडेंट आने तक। उसके बाद डायरेक्टली हम
अपने सेशन को स्टार्ट करेंगे। कंटिन्यू
करेंगे। जहां से हमने अपने सेशन को कहां
पर लास्ट क्लास में छोड़ा था। वहीं से हम
कंटिन्यू करेंगे। बिकॉज़ मैंने आपको कल ये
बताया था कि हमारा जो क्लास का जो रोड मैप
क्या रहेगा दो दिन की क्लास का तो वो रोड
मैप मैं कल की क्लास में डिस्कस कर चुका
हूं। तो अगर आप फर्स्ट टाइम आए हो क्लास
में तो मैं आपको बता देता हूं। ये जो
क्लासेस चल रही हैं ये डीईएचई सीरीज की
क्लासेस हैं। डीएचई मतलब डेफ्रॉनिक्स
एथिकल हैकर एसेंशियल्स जो काफी टाइम से
सीरीज चल रही है। बीच में काफी टाइम के
लिए इसको रोक दिया गया था। कुछ रीजन था बट
अब उसके बाद कंटिन्यू है यह और अभी जो चीज
चल रही है वह चल रही है एक्सटर्नल पेन
टेस्टिंग और एक्सटर्नल पेन टेस्टिंग में
हम सीख रहे हैं क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स
क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स में हम फोकस कर रहे
हैं सोशल इंजीनियरिंग पे तभी जो क्लासेस
चल रही है वो सोशल इंजीनियरिंग की क्लासेस
चल रही हैं और सोशल इंजीनियरिंग बिल्कुल
स्टार्टिंग से चल रहा है बिल्कुल जीरो से
हमने स्टार्ट किया था कि होता क्या है
कैसे काम करता है एथिक्स लीगली ये सारी
चीजें हम डिस्कस कर रहे हैं और अभी जो हम
इस वीक में बात कर रहे हैं प्रिपेयरिंग
फॉरेन अटैक हम कि अटैक करने से पहले
किन-किन चीजों को हमें ध्यान में रखना है।
किन-किन चीजों के बारे में हमें पता होना
चाहिए। वो सारी चीजें हम डिस्कस ऑलरेडी कर
चुके हैं। और बाकी जो बची हुई चीजें हैं
वो भी हम डिस्कस करने वाले हैं। तो इसलिए
मैं आपसे पूछ रहा था कि अगर आपको कोई भी
डाउट है रिलेटेड टू द क्लास तो मुझसे पूछ
सकते हो। तो आज क्लास में कौन-कौन फर्स्ट
टाइम आया है या पुराने स्टूडेंट है सभी?
बताओ मेरे मेरे पास क्योंकि मैं अभी आप
लोगों की धीरे-धीरे एक अटेंडेंस शीट ओपन
करने वाला हूं और वहां पे आपकी अटेंडेंस
लूंगा। उसके बेनिफिट मैं बाद में उनको
दूंगा।
आप साइबर सिक्योरिटी की बात कर रहे हो तो
सर्टिफिकेट का तो कह नहीं सकता लेकिन मैं
आपको यह बता रहा हूं कि आप यहां पर साइबर
सिक्योरिटी की ही ट्रेनिंग ले रहे हो।
क्योंकि मैं कोई नॉर्मल क्लासेस नहीं पढ़ा
रहा। मैं आपको जो क्लासेस पढ़ा रहा हूं वो
वो ऐसी क्लासेस हैं कि जो आपको पेड
ट्रेनिंग में भी नहीं मिलती। मैं लिटरली
बोल रहा हूं बहुत सारे ऐसे कोर्सेज हैं जो
आप बिल्कुल आप फर्स्ट डे से बिल्कुल डे
जीरो से अगर क्लास स्टार्ट कर रहे हो
साइबर सिक्योरिटी सीखना चाह रहे हो आप और
एंट्री लेना चाह रहे हो उस फील्ड में तो
जो कोर्सेज आप 20000 50000 उसके बाद जो
कोर्सेज आप इवन हम एग्जांपल लेते हैं
ईजीपीटी ईजीपीटी बहुत सारे सर्टिफिकेशन है
उसके जो सर्टिफिकेशन है ईजीपीटी ईसीसी
ईसीपीपीटी ऐसे समथिंग जो सर्टिफिकेशंस है
या और भी बहुत सारे सर्टिफिकेशन है वी3
मे बी
हां V3 V12 ये सारी चीजें तो ये ये चीजें
आप पैसे पे करते हो उसके बाद सीखने की आप
कोशिश करते हो तो मैं ये सारी चीजें फ्री
में पढ़ा रहा हूं क्योंकि मेरा गोल मेरा
मोटो जो मेरा मोटिव है वो काफी लॉन्ग है।
मुझे आप लोगों को सिखाना है। तो इसलिए मैं
यह सारी चीजें आपको फ्री में पढ़ा रहा
हूं। आप लोगों को आज यह चीजें ऐसी लग रही
है कि पता नहीं आप सर हम फर्स्ट टाइम ऐसी
चीजें देख रहे हैं कि
YouTube क्लासेस में कि क्या चल रहा है यह
एथिक्स लीगल की बातें स्कोप डिस्कशन ये
चीजें जो पता नहीं आप डे 60 से जो सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग में ये चीज तो हम फर्स्ट टाइम
सुन रहे हैं। फर्स्ट टाइम ये चीजें डिस्कस
हो रही हैं। यह डिस्कस करनी बहुत ज्यादा
जरूरी है। क्योंकि यह वो चीजें हैं जो जब
आप रियल वर्ल्ड में या आप बात कर रहे हैं
किसी कंपनी में एज ए जूनियर पेंटेस्टर
हायर किए जाओगे तो हो सकता है यह चीजें
आपको डील ना करने को मिले क्योंकि आपके
ऊपर कोई ना कोई एक सीनियर अथॉरिटी होगी या
कोई ना कोई आपका मैनेजर्स या आपका
सुपरवाइजर्स होंगे। बट धीरे-धीरे आपको जब
वह चीजें नोटिस करोगे आपको पता चलेगा कि
वह किस किस तरह से इन चीजों को डील करते
हैं। किस तरह से वो
चीजें मेक श्योर कर रहे हैं। तो यह वही
चीजें हैं जो वे मेक श्योर करते हैं जो वह
चीजें डील करते हैं। और फॉर योर काइंड
इंफॉर्मेशन मैं जो कुछ भी चीजें आपको पढ़ा
रहा हूं। कुछ भी अपने मन से नहीं पढ़ा रहा
क्योंकि कहीं भी आप बोलोगे कि कहीं से उठा
के पढ़ा रहा हूं। एआई से पढ़ा रहा हूं।
ऐसा भी नहीं है। मैं आपको जो चीज पढ़ा रहा
हूं ये इवन लेटेस्ट बुक्स हैं जो बहुत
सारी बुक्स अवेलेबल्स हैं। बहुत सारी
बुक्स के कॉम्बिनेशंस है जो मैंने अपने
ड्यूरिंग स्टडी आपके लेक्चर्स प्रिपेयर
करने के लिए उनको बुकों को मैंने खुद
पर्सनली पढ़ा है। मैंने प्रैक्टिकल्स खुद
देखे हैं करके। देन ओनली उनके बाद मैंने
रिसर्च किया। देन आपको यह कंटेंट मैं आपको
पढ़ा रहा हूं। मैं कुछ भी अपने पास से
नहीं पढ़ा रहा। बट यह है कि मैंने थोड़े
स्कोप को थोड़े आपके कंटेंट को मॉडिफाई
किया है। आपको डिलीवरी को मॉडिफाई किया
है। उसमें कुछ ऐसी ऐड की है जो आपको लगता
है कि कि मुझे यह चीज सीखनी चाहिए। पता
नहीं क्या सीख रहा हूं मैं।
देयर आर ओनली थ्री स्टूडेंट। चलिए फिर हम
सेशन को कंटिन्यू करते हैं। मुझे पता है
कोई नहीं आने वाला।
चलो फिर
तो जो हमारा टॉपिक चल रहा था वो टॉपिक था
हमारा प्रिपेयरिंग फॉरेन अटैक। ओके। तो
उसमें हमने क्या-क्या चीज डिस्कस कर चुके
हैं उसके बारे में बात करते हैं हम।
जैसे कि यह हो गया टॉपिक कवर्ड। सबसे पहले
हमने बात की थी कि कोऑर्डिनेटिंग विद द
क्लाइंट। हमने स्कोप डिस्कशन करते वक्त
हमने यह बात की थी कि सबसे पहले हमारा काम
होता है क्लाइंट के साथ आमने-सामने बैठकर
बात करना। अपना स्कोप डिस्कशन करना। अब
उसके बाद स्कोप डिस्कशन करने के बाद मैंने
आपको बताया था स्टेटमेंट ऑफ वर्क क्या
होता है? या रूल्स ऑफ इंगेजमेंट क्या होती
है? ये चीज हम कल की क्लास में डिस्कस कर
चुके हैं। कि जब आप एक बार स्कोप डिस्कशन
कर लेते हो सारी बात क्या करना है? क्या
नहीं करना है? क्या आपके इन स्कोप है?
क्या आउट ऑफ स्कोप है? ये सारी चीजें आप
एक बार डिस्कस कर लेते हो। उसके बाद एक
कॉन्ट्रैक्ट बनाया जाता है। उस
कॉन्ट्रैक्ट को हम बोलते हैं स्टेटमेंट ऑफ
वर्क। और स्टेटमेंट ऑफ वर्क के अंदर क्या
मेंशन होता है? आपका स्टेट मेंशन होता है
रूल्स ऑफ इंगेजमेंट। ये चीज मैं आपको कल
की क्लास में मैंने कवर कर चुका हूं। उसके
बाद मैंने आपको एक चीज बताया था कि अगर
स्टेटमेंट ऑफ वर्क जब आपका डिजाइन होता है
वो उस टाइम पे आपके कुछ सिनेरियो मैंने
डिस्कस किए थे। कुछ गलतियां भी हो सकती
हैं। स्कोप भी गलत आपका स्कोप गलत बन सकता
है या कुछ चीजें आपसे गलत हो सकती हैं।
उसको प्रोटेक्ट करने के लिए एक इंश्योरेंस
होता है जो आपकी कंपनी आपको प्रोवाइड करती
है। नहीं है तो आपको उसप भी पता होना
चाहिए। इंश्योरेंस कौन सा आपका? ई एंड ओ
इंश्योरेंस। ई एंड ओ इंश्योरेंस क्या था
आपका? एरर एंड ओिशन इंश्योरेंस। इसमें यह
क्या चीज होती है? मैंने आपको बताया था।
ऑडिट ट्रायल क्या होता है? यह भी मैंने
आपको बताया था। ओके? ओरल ऑथराइजेशन आपके
पास किसी काम का नहीं होता। इस चीज पे भी
हमने डिस्कशन किया था। हमने यह डिस्कशन
किया था कि इंटेंट और एक्शन में क्या
डिफरेंस है? आपका इंटेंट कितना ही अच्छा
अच्छा क्यों ना हो लेकिन जब बात आती है
साइबर लॉ की जब बात आती है कोर्ट की तो वो
आपके इंटेंट नहीं देखते। वो आपके
ऑथराइजेशन को देखते हैं। ये चीज हमने
क्लियरली देखी थी। उसके बाद एरर एंड ओेशन
इंश्योरेंस के बारे में हमने अच्छे से
डिस्कस किया था। उसके बाद जो लास्ट टॉपिक
जो हमने डिस्कस किया था जो हमने डिस्कस
किया था कि अगर जो स्कोपिंग आपकी पुअर है
ओके और आप तो उसकी वजह से क्या-क्या हो
सकता है ठीक है अगर आपकी स्कोपिंग पुअर है
तो क्या होगा आपकी इंगेजमेंट फेल होगी तो
इंगेजमेंट फेल होने के क्सिक्वेंसेस क्या
रहेंगे उसके बाद अगर आपको स्कोपिंग अच्छे
से मेंटेन करनी है आपको अच्छी स्कोपिंग
डिस्कशन करनी है तो उसके लिए हम क्या करते
हैं स्कोपिंग वर्कशीट का यूज़ कर अह
वर्कशीट का यूज़ करते हैं उस वो चीज़ यहां
तक हम डिस्कस कर चुके हैं। तो यह सारी
चीजें हम कल की क्लास में हमने डिस्कस
किया था। तो आज की जो क्लास स्टार्ट होने
वाली है वह स्टार्ट होने वाली है तीन
टॉपिक पर डिफाइनिंग असेसमेंट ऑब्जेक्टिव
सिलेक्टिंग मेथड्स एंड टेक्निक देन उसके
बाद बिल्डिंग इफेक्टिव सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
प्री टेक्स्ट बिल्डिंग मतलब वहां पे हम
डिस्कस करने वाले हैं क्योंकि देखो ये
सारी चीजें वन बाय वन है। ये ऐसा नहीं कि
डायरेक्टली आप स्कोपिंग वर्कशीट दिखाओगे।
नहीं हर एक चीज स्टेप बाय स्टेप हो रही
है। फर्स्ट, सेकंड, थर्ड हर एक चीज ये
सारी चीज आपके आपके लिए सोचने की बात है।
ऐसे नहीं कि आप मैं आप डायरेक्टली
क्सिक्वेंसेस के बारे में बात करने लग
जाओगे। नहीं सारी चीज स्टेप स्टेप बाय
स्टेप है। आपका क्लाइंट के साथ बैठोगे,
मीटिंग करोगे देन आप स्कोप डिस्कशन कर
सकते हो। ये सारी चीज कर सकते हो। तो
नेक्स्ट तो अभी हम स्टार्ट करते हैं
डिफाइनिंग ऑब्जेक्टिव। हम डिफाइनिंग
ऑब्जेक्टिव से स्टार्ट करते हैं। तो यू
हैव साइन द कॉन्ट्रैक्ट एंड स्टेटमेंट ऑफ
वर्क इज रेडी। मतलब अब तक हमने क्या किया?
अपना कॉन्ट्रैक्ट साइन कर लिया। और अब
हमारा जो स्टेटमेंट ऑफ वर्क है वह भी रेडी
है। जैसे कि हमने कल की क्लास में डिस्कस
किया था कि कॉन्ट्रैक्ट और स्टेटमेंट ऑफ
वर्क आपका रेडी है। तो नेक्स्ट स्टेप इज
डिफाइनिंग ऑब्जेक्टिव। मतलब अब हमारा अगला
स्टेप क्या है? ऑब्जेक्टिव डिफाइन करना।
ओके? यू मस्ट क्लियरली विद योर क्लाइंट
व्हाट इज द ट्रू मिशन ऑफ दिस पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्ट। दिस पेनिट्रेशन टेस्ट। मतलब आपको
अपने क्लाइंट के साथ क्लियर करना पड़ेगा
कि इस पेन टेस्टिंग का असली मोटो क्या है?
असली मकसद क्या है? मेन गोल क्या है? मतलब
आप यह पेन टेस्टिंग क्यों करवा रहे हो? तो
डिफरेंट-डिफरेंट कंपनीज़ हैव
डिफरेंट-डिफरेंट मोटिव्स। अलग-अलग कंपनीज़
के अलग-अलग मोटिव्स हो सकते हैं। जैसे फॉर
एग्जांपल फर्स्ट पॉइंट नंबर वन डिफेंसिव
अपग्रेड। मतलब
इज दी कंपनी कंडक्टिंग दिस टेस्ट टू
कन्वेंस मैनेजमेंट दैट दे नीड टू इन्वेस्ट
इन न्यू सिक्योरिटी टूल्स एंड
टेक्नोलॉजीज़? मतलब क्या है कि क्या यह
क्या कंपनी यह टेस्ट इसलिए करवा रही है
ताकि वह मैनेजमेंट को एग्री करवा सके,
कन्विंस करवा सके कि नए सिक्योरिटी टूल्स
और टेक्नोलॉजी खरीदने की जरूरत है। हम
आउटडेटेड हो चुके हैं। क्या यह टेस्ट
इसलिए हो रहा है? या दूसरा पॉइंट क्या हो
सकता है? ह्यूमन कैपिटल असेसमेंट। ह्यूमन
कैपिटल असेसमेंट का मतलब आर दे आर चेकिंग
वेदर देयर एंप्लई नीड मोर ट्रेनिंग एंड
सिक्योरिटी अवेयरनेस। या वह यह चेक कर रहे
हैं कि क्या उनके एंप्लई को और ज्यादा
ट्रेनिंग की रिक्वायरमेंट है। क्या उनके
ट्रेनिंग जो वर्कशॉप है या ट्रेनिंग उनकी
जो पॉलिसीज है उनको अपडेट करने की जरूरत
है? क्या उनके उनको ज्यादा ट्रेनिंग की
रिक्वायरमेंट या इस ट्रेनिंग से काम चल
जाएगा। वह फुल्ली अवेयर हैं। तो ये चीज
है। थर्ड ऑब्जेक्टिव क्या हो सकता है?
मोटिव क्या हो सकता है? कंप्लायंस चेक। इज
द इज द टेस्ट बीइंग डन ओनली टू मीट ए
गवर्नमेंट रेगुलेशंस और कंप्लायंस
रिक्वायरमेंट। क्या यह टेस्ट सिर्फ इसलिए
हो रहा है क्योंकि किसी गवर्नमेंट रूल या
कंप्लायंस को पूरा करना है। मतलब
गवर्नमेंट ने कोई नई पॉलिसी पास की है।
कोई गवर्नमेंट की नई पॉलिसी आई है या कुछ
एक नया कंप्लायंस आया है। मतलब आप कोई भी
फॉर एग्जांपल पीसी आईडीएसएस हो सकता है
आईएसओ या कोई ऐसी पॉलिसी आई है जिसको बोला
गया है कि सभी कंपनी को वो इंप्लीमेंट
करनी है। तो आप वो कंप्लायंस चेक करने के
लिए उस पॉलिसी इंप्लीमेंट करने के लिए
क्या कर रहे हो? यह टेस्ट करवा रहे हो।
नेक्स्ट मोटिव क्या हो सकता है?
परफॉर्मेंस इवोल्यूशन। परफॉर्मेंस
इवोल्यूशन मतलब आप यह टेस्ट इस टेस्ट से
यह देखना चाहते हो कि आपकी जो सिक्योरिटी
टीम है उसकी एफिशिएंसी क्या है? आप उसकी
बेसिकली एफिशिएंसी चेक करना चाहते हो।
उसके बेस पर आप क्या करना चाहते हो? उनके
जो रेजेस है, रेज है, उनकी सैलरी बढ़ानी
है, घटानी है, उनको मतलब या फिर आप क्या
करना चाह रहे हो? उनको रिप्लेस करना चाह
रहे हो या अपग्रेड करना चाह रहे हो। ये
सारी चीजें अगर उनका परफॉर्मेंस इवोल्यूशन
देखने के लिए आप टेस्टिंग करवा रहे हो तो
यह भी एक मोटिव हो सकता है कंपनी का। तो
बेसिकली आपका मेन काम क्या है? आपको
ऑब्जेक्टिव जानना है। मतलब आपका आपको यह
जानना है कि यह पेन टेस्टिंग किस पर्पस से
हो रही है? एंड द आंसर टू दीज़ क्वेश्चन
शुड नॉट चेंज हाउ यू वर्क। यू मस्ट ऑलवेज
डिलीवर योर बेस्ट। कहने का मतलब क्या है
कि इन सवालों के जवाब से आपके काम करने के
तरीके में कोई भी फर्क नहीं पड़ना चाहिए।
आपको हमेशा पेन टेस्टिंग में खुद का या
अपना बेस्ट ही देना है। आपको क्या करना है
कि सवालों के जवाबों के अकॉर्डिंग आपको
पेन टेस्टिंग नहीं करनी है। बट इट हेल्प
यू अंडरस्टैंड द क्लाइंट एक्सपेक्टेशंस
एंड हाउ टू फ्रेम योर फाइनल रिपोर्ट
इफेक्टिवली।
बेसिकली क्या होगा? इससे हमें क्या फायदा
होगा? इससे आपको यह पता चलेगा। यह समझने
में मदद मिलेगी कि क्लाइंट की
एक्सपेक्टेशन क्या है? और आपको अपनी फाइनल
रिपोर्ट कैसे फ्रेम करनी है जो आपकी जो
फाइनल रिपोर्ट होगी जो आपको सबमिट करनी है
आफ्टर पेन टेस्टिंग उसमें कंपनी की
रिक्वायरमेंट क्या है कंपनी क्या चाहती है
उसी के हिसाब से आप अपनी फाइनल रिपोर्ट
सबमिट करोगे तो इससे आपको सिर्फ इतनी ही
हेल्प मिलेगी बट आपकी जो पेन टेस्टिंग की
जो अप्रोच रहेगी या आपको जिस तरीके से
आपको पेन टेस्टिंग करनी है उसमें आपको को
कुछ भी फेरबदल नहीं करना है कुछ भी चेंज
नहीं करना है। नेक्स्ट आता है आपका
डिफाइनिंग मेथड्स एंड टेक्नोलॉजीज़। आफ्टर
ऑब्जेक्टिव इज़ टाइम टु डिसाइड द मेथड्स
व्हिच पाथ विल यू चूज़ ड्यूरिंग पेन
टेस्टिंग। ऑब्जेक्टिव के बाद बारी आती है
आपके मेथड डिसाइड करने की। आप कौन सा मेथड
यूज़ करोगे या कौन सा पाथ आप यूज़ करोगे
ड्यूरिंग पेन टेस्टिंग? यह डिस्कस करना भी
बहुत जरूरी है। यू मस्ट डिस्कस दीज़
पॉइंट्स विद द क्लाइंट। कि इसके लिए भी
आपको क्लाइंट से क्या करना है? इन बातों
पर डिस्कस करना है कि आप कौन सा पाथ यूज
करोगे पेन टेस्टिंग के दौरान। यू कैन नॉट
से जस्ट से वी विल डू फेसिंग। आप क्लाइंट
को सिर्फ यह नहीं बोल सकते कि हम फेसिंग
करेंगे। आपको उनको बताना पड़ेगा। उनको
बताना होगा कि आप किस तरह का अटैक सिमुलेट
करने वाले हो। किस तरह का अटैक आप सिमुलेट
करोगे। बिकॉज़ एव्री मेथड सिमुलेट डिफरेंट
अटैक्स एंड टेस्ट डिफरेंट सिक्योरिटी
कंट्रोल्स। क्योंकि
हर मेथड क्लाइंट के अलग-अलग सिक्योरिटी
कंट्रोल्स को टेस्ट करता है। एंड
डिसाइडिंग मेथड डज नॉट मीन व्हाट यू कैन
डू इट मींस व्हाट द क्लाइंट अलाउज यू टू
सिमुलेट। अब मेथड डिसाइड करने का मतलब यह
नहीं है कि आप क्या-क्या कर सकते हो। इसका
मतलब यह यह जानना है कि क्लाइंट आपको किस
हद तक सिमुलेट करने की परमिशन दे रहा है।
अगर आप मेथड जब मेथड डिसाइड की बात हो रही
है, डिस्कशन चल रहा है कि हम कौन सा मेथड
यूज़ करना करेंगे, कौन-कौन से मेथड हम यूज़
कर सकते हैं। कौन-कौन सा मेथड हम यूज़ नहीं
करने वाले तो जब यह डिस्कशन होता है तो
इसका मतलब यह नहीं है कि वो इसमें आपकी
कैपेबिलिटी कम होती है। नहीं, आप बेसिकली
क्लाइंट के मन की बात जानना चाहते हो।
क्लाइंट से यह जानना चाहते हो कि वह किस
हद तक आपके परमिशन दे रहा है। किस हद तक
आप अपना सिमुलेशन परफॉर्म कर सकते हो।
ओके? एंड इफ मेथड्स आर नॉट क्लियर इन
एडवांस द इंगेजमेंट कैन टर्न इनू अ रियल
अटैक एंड और फेल कंप्लीटली। अगर मेथड पहले
से क्लियर नहीं है तो इंगेजमेंट या तो
रियल साइबर अटैक में बदल जाएगी या फिर
पूरी तरह से फेल हो जाएगी। चारों पॉइंट आई
होप सबको समझ में आ गया होगा कि यह
क्या-क्या चीजें हैं। नाउ ए रियल थ्रेट
एक्टर्स लाइक ब्लैक हेट हैकर्स विल डू
एनीथिंग। अब एक जो रियल थ्रेट एक्टर्स
होता है जिसको हम ब्लैक हैकर्स भी बोल
सकते हैं वो कुछ भी करेगा। बट एन एथिकल
हैकर्स नीड क्लियर रिटर्न साइन ऑफ फॉर्म
फ्रॉम द क्लाइंट। मतलब कि जब बात आती है
एक एथिकल हैकर की एक
पेंटेस्टर की वह क्या करता है वह क्लाइंट
से एक क्लियर साइन ऑफ फॉर्म लेता है एक
अप्रूवल लेता है क्लियर साइन ऑफ का मतलब
क्लाइंट की तरफ से एकदम बिल्कुल साफ पक्की
और रिटर्न अप्रूवल या परमिशन जिसमें कोई
भी इफ या बट जैसे क्लोज ना हो बिल्कुल
साफ-साफ करना है या नहीं करना है इफ और बट
क्लोज ना हो। ठीक है? अब बात करते हैं कि
एज ए पेंटस्टर्स हम करंट से कौन-कौन से
टेक्न जैसे कि आपके मन में कौन-कौन सी
टेक्निक चल रही होंगी। बेसिकली आपके मन
में चार पांच टेक्निक ही चलेंगी। जैसे
टाइप ऑफ डोमेन स्क्वेडिंग है, इंपस्टुएशन
हो गया, अटैक वेक्टर्स हो गया, चेनिंग
अटैक हो गया, ऑटोमेशन या मैनुअल्स। ओके?
तो यही आपके मन में चार पांच टेक्निक चल
रही चल रही होंगी। तो मैं हर एक टेक्निक
का नाम लेता हूं। आपको समझाने की कोशिश
करता हूं। तो उसके बाद आपको क्लाइंट से
क्या डिस्कस करना है, वह भी मैं आपको
बताऊंगा। ओके। तो चलो बात करते हैं। सबसे
पहले बात करते टाइप ऑफ डोमेन स्कडिंग। ठीक
है? मतलब एज ए पेंट्रेसर अगर आप क्लाइंट
के डोमेन से कोई मिलताजुलता
या गलत स्पेलिंग वाला डोमेन खरीदना चाहते
हो। ठीक है? मतलब आप यह अटैक परफॉर्म करने
के लिए आप टाइप ऑफ या डोमेन स्क्वाडिंग
अटैक परफॉर्म करने की सोच रहे हो तो उसके
लिए आपको क्या करना पड़ेगा? उस क्लाइंट के
डोमेन से मिलताजुलता या गलत स्पेलिंग वाला
डोमेन खरीदना पड़ेगा। जैसे google.com है।
इसमें आप क्या करोगे? जी ओ जी एल ई.com यह
आप परचेज करोगे। ओके यह परचेस करना चाह जो
कि क्या है? इट इज ए वेरी इफेक्टिव
टेक्निक बिकॉज़ पीपल डू नॉट नोटिस स्पेलिंग
मिस्टेक्स इन ए हरी और डिफरेंट टीएलडीस।
मतलब यह बहुत इफेक्टिव टेक्निक है।
क्योंकि लोग जल्दबाजी में गलत स्पेलिंग्स
पर ध्यान नहीं देते। या तो आगे वाली
स्पेलिंग पे ध्यान देते हैं या पीछे वाली
स्पेलिंग पे ध्यान देते हैं। कंप्लीट
स्पेलिंग का वो कभी भी नहीं पढ़ते हैं। या
फिर आप क्या करोगे जो टॉप लेवल डोमेन है
उसका उसको क्या करोगे आप टॉप लेवल डोमेनस
को
सेम नाम के टॉप लेवल डोमेनस है उसको
खरीदोगे लेकिन थोड़ा सा चेंज कर जैसे कि
nsc.com है उसको आप क्या करोगे? nshchus
से। ठीक है? अब क्लाइंट से आपको क्या
डिस्कस करना है? आस्क द क्लाइंट इफ वी कैन
परचेस लुक अ लाइक डोमेनस टू टेस्ट देर
ब्रांड मॉनिटरिंग एंड ईमेल सिक्योरिटी।
मतलब आपको क्लाइंट से पूछना है क्या हम
उनकी ब्रांड मॉनिटरिंग और ईमेल सिक्योरिटी
को टेस्ट करने के लिए उनसे मिलताजुलता
डोमेन खरीद सकते हैं यस या नो। यहां पर यस
या नो चाहिए आपको रिटर्न में। ठीक है? ठीक
है? या फिर आप दूसरा अटैक परफॉर्म करना
चाहते हो। इंपर्स क्या मतलब? इंपर्स।
मतलब क्या मतलब आप उनके किसी वेंडरर्स
किसी क्लाइंट या पार्टनर के रूप में उनको
मैनपुलेट करना चाह रहे हो। आप सोचोगे या
तो कोई आप वेंडर वेंडर का प्री टेक्स्ट
यूज़ करोगे या कोई पार्टनर का या फिर
क्लाइंट का। तो आप
तो फिर आपको क्लाइंट से क्या डिस्कस करना
है? डू वी हैव परमिशन टू इमपर्सनेट इंटरनल
एंप्लॉय और ट्रस्टेड थर्ड पार्टीज लाइक
आईटी स्पॉट एचआर पे रोल प्रोवाइडर्स? मतलब
मतलब यह है कि क्लाइंट से आपको यह पूछना
है कि क्या हम कोई इंटरनल एंप्लई या उनके
ट्रस्टेड थर्ड पार्टी वेंडरर्स जैसे आईटी
सपोर्ट हो गया या फिर जो एचआर पे पेरोल
जो सॉफ्टवेयर प्रोवाइडर्स है उनका प्री
टेक्स्ट यूज कर सकते हैं। उनका नाम यूज कर
सकते हैं। क्या उनके उनकी तरह वो बनकर हम
बात कर सकते हैं। क्या यह परमिशन है या
नहीं है? क्योंकि देयर आर सम कंपनीज
कंसीडर एचआर एंड सीओ इंपसुशन अनहाइजीनिक
एज इट ब्रेक्स इंटरनल ट्रस्ट तो गेट इट ए
क्लियर यस या नो क्योंकि कुछ कंपनीज ऐसी
हैं जो क्या करती हैं कि जो एचआर या जो
सीईओ के नाम पर जब आप इंपर्स करने की के
लिए परमिशन मांगते हो तो वो क्या मानती है
उसको अनहाइजीनिक मानती है उसको सही नहीं
मानती क्योंकि इससे क्या होता है जो
एंप्लॉय है और जो बॉस है उसके बीच का जो
इंटरनल ट्रस्ट है वह टूट जाता है इसलिए वह
क्या करते हैं? इस पर क्लियर यस या नो
चाहिए होता है कि हमें यह चीज कर सकते हैं
नहीं कर सकते। यस या नो। हां, तो ठीक है,
नहीं है तो भी ठीक है। नेक्स्ट हम बात
करते हैं अटैक वेक्टर। नेक्स्ट बात करते
हैं हम अटैक वेक्टर की। मतलब आपका गोल
क्या है?
आप क्या चाह रहे हो? एज ए पेंटेस्टर व्हाट
इज द गोल? व्हाट डू यू वांट द यूजर टू डू?
आप क्या चाह रहे हो? आप क्या मशियस
डॉक्यूमेंट डाउनलोड करवाना चाह रहे हो? या
कोई फेक लॉगिन पेज क्रिएट करके उससे
क्रेडेंशियल स्टील करवाना चाह रहे हो।
मतलब एज ए पेंट्रेसर आप क्या करवाना चाह
रहे हो? यह आपको पता है। ठीक है? तो यह
चीज आपको क्या डिस्कस करनी है? कंफर्म द
एग्जैक्ट अटैक वेक्टर्स एंड द यूजर एक्शन
यू आर अलाउड टू सिमुलेट। आप बताओगे कि
मेरा गोल यह है। मैं कोई एक मिलेशियस
डॉक्यूमेंट डाउनलोड करवाऊंगा या मैं एक
फेक लॉगिन पेज क्रिएट करके उनसे क्लिक
करवा के क्रेडिट्स लूंगा। तो ये चीज आपको
पूछना है। क्या यह करना? क्या ये मैं कर
सकता हूं नहीं कर सकता ये आपको क्लाइंट से
डिस्कस करना है। नेक्स्ट चैन चेंजिंग अटैक
मतलब आप आप सोच रहे हो कि जो वििंग है
वॉइस कॉल है जो फिशिंग है उन दोनों को
क्या करना आप चेंज करने की सोच रहे हो कि
मैं विशिंग का यूज करूंगा उसके बाद फिशिंग
यूज़ करूंगा उसके बाद अपना अटैक सिंपलेट
करूंगा मतलब कंबाइनिंग ए वॉइस कॉल एंड
ईमेल ड्रामेटिकली इनक्रीज सक्सेस रेट 80%
एज द यूजर इज मेंटली प्रिपयर्ड क्योंकि
मतलब पहले आप फोन करके बोलोगे कि मैं आपको
एक ईमेल भेज रहा हूं और फिर आप उसको ईमेल
भेज दोगे इससे बेनिफिट क्या होगा कि आपका
जो सक्सेस रेट है वो 80% से भी ज्यादा हो
जाता है क्योंकि जो यूज़र्स है वो आप पर
ट्रस्ट करता है और आपसे वो मेंटली
प्रिपेयर हो चुका है कि एक ईमेल आने वाली
है उस पे उसको क्लिक करना है रिएक्ट करना
है तो आपको पूछना है क्लाइंट से डू वी हैव
परमिशंस फॉर हाइब्रिड एग्जीक्यूशन मतलब
क्या हमें इस हाइब्रिड एग्जीक्यूशन की
परमिशन है क्या हम चेनिंग
फिशिंग फिशिंग इनका चेनिंग अटैक परफॉर्म
कर सकते हैं क्योंकि नाउ डेज चेंजिंग अटैक
ही परफॉर्म किया जाता है। कोई भी सिंगल
टेक्निक यूज़ नहीं की जाती। तो उसके बाद
फिफ्थ पॉइंट आ गया आपका क्लाइंट ऑटोमेशन
वर्सेस मैनुअल। आप क्या चाहते हो? आप या
आप बोलोगे कि मैं एक ऑटोमेशन टूल्स यूज़
करना चाहता हूं या फिर मैं मैनुअली
टेस्टिंग। तो आपको क्लाइंट से डिस्कस करना
है कि आर वी अलाउड टू यूज़ एनी ऑटोमेटेड
टूल्स और शुड दी एंटायर इंगेजमेंट बी
परफॉर्म्ड मैनुअली? क्या हम ऑटोमेटेड
टूल्स का यूज कर सकते हैं टेस्टिंग
परफॉर्म करने के लिए पूरा का पूरा जो
प्रोसेस हमें मैनुअल करना पड़ेगा। ओके?
तो, यह सारी चीजें आप क्या करोगे? अपने जो
मेथड्स हैं, जो आपके टेक्निक्स हैं, आपको
क्लाइंट के साथ डिस्कस करना है। उसके बाद
आपको यह भी रिटर्न में लेना है। बिकॉज़
आपने डिस्कस किया क्लाइंट ने आपको बोला
ओके? आप ये कर सकते हो। हमें कोई प्रॉब्लम
नहीं है। और आप यह चैनिंग अटैक या आपका जो
गोल है आप कर लेना और हमें बताते रहना। तो
ये आपको डिस्कस करना होगा। ऐसे नहीं कि आप
आपने डिस्कस किया नहीं और डायरेक्टली अटैक
करना स्टार्ट कर दिया। ये भी आपको डिस्कस
करना है। मैं आपको सारी चीजें वो बता रहा
हूं जो आपको करना चाहिए। अब रियल वर्ल्ड
में क्या-क्या होता है, क्या-क्या नहीं
होता। थोड़ा सा डिफरेंशिएट करता है
क्योंकि आप ये सारी परमिशंस लेते हो। ये
सारी परमिशन लेने के बाद अलर्ट मिल जाते
हैं उनको। कंपनी ज्यादा अलर्ट रहती है। तो
वो भी आप डिस्कस कर सकते हो कि देखो आपकी
मर्जी है। मैं सारी चीजें इसलिए डिस्कस कर
रहा हूं। मेरा अटैक का तरीका यह रहेगा।
टेक्निक यह रहेगी। आपको इसलिए बता दिया
लेकिन अगर आप अपने एंप्लॉय को अपने
अथॉरिटीज को अगर आप
अवेयर करके रखोगे, बता के रखोगे तो इससे
फायदा कुछ नहीं होगा क्योंकि हमारी
टेस्टिंग तो फेल हो जाएगी। बट जब भी कोई
अटैक होगा रियल अटैक होगा वो कभी भी बताकर
नहीं होता। अब डिपेंड करता है कि वो बस
हां करंट सिनेरियो में टेस्टिंग करवा के
बस आप आपको गलत प्रूव करना चाहते हैं या
फिर आप फ्यूचर अपने फ्यूचर सिक्योर करना
चाहता है। टोटली डिपेंड्स ऑन द
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन। बट आपका काम है एथिकली
ऑपरेट करना सारी चीजें डिस्कस करते हुए सो
दैट कि क्लेरिटी बनी रहे।
आई होप कि सारी चीजें यहां तक आपको समझ
में आ रही होंगी। बिकॉज़ जो हैकिंग है ना
वह एक टेक्निकल स्किल है। जो हैकिंग है ना
आपकी वो एक टेक्निकल स्किल है। और जो पेन
टेस्टिंग है वो एक प्रोफेशनल फ्रेमवर्क
है। इसलिए मैंने आपको पहले ही बोला था कि
मेथड डिसाइड करने का मतलब यह नहीं है कि
आप क्या-क्या तोड़फोड़ मचा सकते हो। बल्कि
आपका मेन गोल यह है कि आप क्लाइंट का जो
साइबर डिफेंस है उसको सेफ किस तरीके से कर
सकते हो। यह चीज आपका मेन गोल है। एवरीवन
अंडरस्टुड दे आर जितने मैं देख पा रहा हूं
दे आर 10 स्टूडेंट्स। तो ऑल स्टूडेंट्स आर
सबको समझ में आ गया?
एवरीवन सबको क्लियर है?
इट्स ओके नीरज बाकी नीरज अभी जो मैं करंट
आपको बता रहा हूं वो आपको समझ में आ गया?
जो चीज अभी मैंने आपके सामने डिस्कस की वह
क्लियर है।
क्लियर है? चलो फिर
तो नेक्स्ट हम चलते हैं जो नेक्स्ट हमारा
टॉपिक है बिल्डिंग सक्सेसफुल प्रीटेक्स्ट।
अब आते हैं सबसे मजेदार टॉपिक पर।
प्रीक्स्ट बिल्डिंग।
प्रिटेक्स्ट मींस एक्सक्यूज और ए स्टोरी
दैट यू क्रिएट टू ट्रिक योर टारगेट। मतलब
प्रिटेक का मतलब होता है एक कहानी या
बहाना बनाना जो आप अपने टारगेट को ट्रिक
करने के लिए, मैनपुलेट करने के लिए,
फंसाने के लिए बनाते हो। बट
प्री टेक्स्टिंग इज नॉट जस्ट ए स्टोरी। इट
इज ए साइकोलॉजिकल गेम प्लेड विद द टारगेट
माइंड। अगर हम सही मायनों में बात करें
प्री टेक्स्टिंग सिर्फ एक कहानी बनाना
नहीं है। बल्कि टारगेट के दिमाग के साथ
साइकोलॉजिकल गेम खेलना है। एन एडवांस
अटैकर्स ऑलवेज लेवरेज दीज़ थ्री ह्यूमन
इमोशंस और बिहेवियर।
एक जो एडवांस अटैकर्स होता है हमेशा वह
इंसान के तीन इमोशंस और बिहेवियर का फायदा
उठाता है। दे ये जो तीन कॉमन बिहेवियर्स
होते हैं अथॉरिटी, अर्जेंसी और
हेल्पफुलनेस इन तीन जो
इमोशनल
और जो कॉमन बिहेवियर है इन्हीं का सबसे
ज्यादा यूज़ किया जाता है किसके अंदर? प्री
टेक्स्टिंग के अंदर। तो सबसे पहले बात
करते हैं अथॉरिटी की। अथॉरिटी होती है
पावर। व्हेन समवन टॉक्स बाय टेकिंग द नेम
ऑफ आईटी सपोर्ट लीगल टीम और ए सीनियर
वेंडर द नेचुरल इंस्ट ऑफ ह्यूमन इज टू
फॉलो ऑर्डर्स।
जब कोई आईटी स्पोर्ट लीगल टीम या किसी
बड़े वेंडर का नाम लेकर बात करता है तो
इंसान का जो नेचुरल इंस्टिंक्ट होता है जो
नेचुरल नेचर होता है वो होता है ऑर्डर
फॉलो करना। फॉर एग्जांपल हेलो दिस इज
फ्रॉम योर कंपनीज आईटी स्पोर्ट टीम वी नीड
टू वेरीफाई योर अकाउंट टू कंटिन्यू योर
ईमेल एड्रेसेस
तो क्या होता है कि इंसान का बाय डिफॉल्ट
नेचर क्या होता है कि ऑर्डर को फॉलो करना
तो वो क्या कर देते हैं इंफॉर्मेशन दे
देते हैं नेक्स्ट क्या होता है एक इस चीज
का फायदा उठाया जाता है दूसरा होता है
अर्जेंसी अर्जेंसी मतलब जल्दबाजी फॉर
एग्जांपल सर इफ यू डोंट वेरीफाई द डिटेल्स
नाउ योर क्लाउड अकाउंट विल बी ब्लॉक्ड इन
10 मिनट्स एंड ऑल योरेंट डाटा विल बिकम
इनएक्सेसिबल। मतलब सर अगर अभी डिटेल्स
वेरीफाई नहीं की तो आपका क्लाउड अकाउंट 10
मिनट में ब्लॉक हो जाएगा
और आपका जो भी डाटा है वह इनएक्सेबल हो
जाएगा। समझ रहे हो? यह अर्जेंसी है। इफ यू
डोंट डू इट राइट नाउ। इफ यू डोंट डू इट
राइट नाउ। यह जो चीज़ है ना यह जो टर्म है
इस टाइप की जो सिचुएशंस है यह आती है आपको
मतलब आपने अभी नहीं किया तो प्रॉब्लम है
इस टाइप की जो सिचुएशन होती है यह क्या
करती है किसी भी इंसान को इवन जो आपका
टारगेट है उसको सोचने का समय नहीं देती और
अटैकर्स इसका क्या यूज़ इसी का यूज़ करते
हैं इफ यू डोंट डू इट राइट नाउ अगर आपने
अभी नहीं किया तो जब यह चीज यूज़ करते हैं
अटैकर्स यह साइकोलॉजिकल ट्रिक का यूज़ करते
हैं तो अटैकर्स क्या करते हैं? जो टारगेट
है उसको सोचने का टाइम नहीं देते हैं।
इसके वजह से क्या होता है? जो अर्जेंसी
फैक्टर है फोर्स द टारगेट टू मेक डिसीजन
आउट ऑफ ईयर। और जो अटैकर्स हैं
वो टारगेट को इस अर्जेंसी
के मतलब जो अर्जेंसी उन्होंने क्रिएट की
है इसके डर से डिसीजन लेने में क्या करते
हैं? फ़ करते हैं। मतलब टारगेट क्या करता
है? इस डर में क्या करता है? कहीं मेरा
अकाउंट 10 मिनट में ब्लॉक ना हो जाए। कहीं
पर मेरा डाटा जो इंपॉर्टेंट डाटा है वो
इनएक्सेबल ना हो जाए। इस वजह से जो उसको
क्या करना चाहिए? थोड़ा इसके ऊपर सोचना
चाहिए था। वो सोचने की जो पावर थी उसको कम
कर देता है और उसकी वजह से डर के मारे
उसको डिसीजन लेने में क्या करता है?
प्रेशराइज करता है और उसके बाद क्या जो
उसकी लॉजिकल थिंकिंग है वो उसको बाईपास
करता है और वह क्या करता है? एक्शन ले
लेता है। नेक्स्ट थर्ड पॉइंट है आपका
हेल्पफुल नेचर। हेल्प हेल्प मतलब
हेल्पफुलनेस हैबिट टू हेल्प मतलब मदद करने
की आदत एमंप्लाइज यूजली वांट टू कोपरेट
स्पेशली व्हेन दे फील दे आर हेल्पिंग द
कंपनी सॉल्व ए मेजर इशू मतलब एंप्लाइजज़
आमतौर पर कोपरेट करना चाहते हैं और खासकर
तब जब उन्हें लगता है कि वो अपनी कंपनी की
मदद कर रहे हैं किसी बड़े इंसिडेंट को
अवॉइड करने के लिए कुछ मेजर इशू को सॉल्व
करने के लिए फॉर एग्जांपल वी आर कंडक्टिंग
एन इंटरनल सिक्योरिटी ऑडिट टू प्रोटेक्ट
यू फ्रॉम फदर थ्रेड्स। वी जस्ट नीड सम
इंटू मेक आवर सिक्योरिटी स्टंगर। मतलब एक
एंप्लॉय जिसको पता है कि उसको खास हर जगह
इनवॉल्व नहीं किया जाता और लेकिन जब उसको
इस तरीके सेेंस दी जाती है कि ओके वो जो
इंफॉर्मेशन देगा उससे हम अपनी जो हमारी जो
हमारी कंपनी है मतलब हमारी जो कंपनी है
उसको हम क्या कर सकते हैं और भी ज्यादा
स्ट्रांग प्रोटेक्ट कर सकते हैं। हम उस पे
काम कर रहे हैं तो प्लीज आप मुझे तो उसको
ऐसा लगता है कि जो मैं इंफॉर्मेशन दूंगा
मैं वो कंपनी के प्रोटेक्शन के लिए दूंगा।
मतलब उसको आपनेस दी जिसकी वजह से क्या हुआ
उसका हेल्पफुलनेस जो नेचर है मदद करने का
जो नेचर है मदद करने की जो आदत है वो
एक्टिव होती है और जो अटैकर्स है अपना गोल
अचीव कर लेता है ठीक है अटैकर्स क्या होता
है वो अपना गोल अचीव कर लेता है तो ये तीन
कॉमन सबसे ज्यादा सिनेरियोस होते हैं जो
अटैकर्स यूज़ करते हैं एक तो अथॉरिटी यूज़
करते हैं या फिर आपकी अर्जेंसी का फायदा
उठाएंगे या फिर आपके जो मदद करने का नेचर
है उसका फायदा उठाते हैं। दीज़ आर द मोस्ट
कॉमन टेक्निक्स दैट आर यूज्ड बाय एनी सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग अटैक्स।
नेक्स्ट अब बात करते हैं हम
लेवरेजिंग करंट इवेंट्स एंड ओपन सोर्स।
मतलब ए स्मार्ट अटैकर्स यूज़ व्हाट इज
हैपनिंग अराउंड द टारगेट राइट नाउ। मतलब
एक जो स्मार्ट अटैकर्स होता है ना जो
स्मार्ट हैकर्स होता है वह हमेशा इस चीज
पे बहुत ज्यादा ध्यान देता है कि उसके
आसपास क्या चल रहा है जिस जो टारगेट है
टारगेट के अभी हाल में आसपास क्या चीजें
चल रही हैं क्या घटनाएं घट रही हैं उन पे
ज्यादा ध्यान देता है लाइक ए प्रोफेशनल
हैकर ऑलवेज लेवरेज करंट इवेंट हैपनिंग इन
द टारगेट एनवायरमेंट टू बिल्ड बिलीवबल
प्रिटेक्स्ट मतलब क्या है कि एक जो
प्रोफेशनल हैकर्स होता है हमेशा टारगेट
एनवायरमेंट में चल रहे करंट इवेंट का
फायदा उठाता है। जैसे यू कॉल प्रिटेंडिंग
टू बी देयर क्लाउड और ईमेल प्रोवाइडर एंड
से देयर हैज़ बीन अ सिक्योरिटी इंसिडेंट।
आई नीड टू वेरीफाई सम अकाउंट डिटेल्स।
मतलब फॉर एग्जांपल आपने क्या किया? एक
क्लाउड या ईमेल प्रोवाइडर बनकर कॉल किया।
आपने कॉल करके बोला कि एक सिक्योरिटी
इंसिडेंट हुआ है। मुझे आपकी कुछ डिटेल्स
चाहिए। बिल्कुल। एंड कुछ तीन लाइनें लिखी
हुई है जिनका बहुत गहरा मतलब है। तो मैं
उसको एक्सप्लेन करता हूं यहां पर।
रेलेवेंस क्रिएट ट्रस्ट मतलब क्या है? अगर
आपकी बात सामने वाले को वाले के जो आपकी
जो बात है अगर वो सामने वाले के काम की है
तो उनका ट्रस्ट आप पर बनता है। मतलब जो आप
बात उसे अप्रोच कर रहे हो अगर वो उसके काम
की है तो वो आप पर ट्रस्ट करेगा। दूसरा
ट्रस्ट क्रिएट कंप्लायंस। मतलब जब ट्रस्ट
बनता है तो लोग आपकी बात मानने को भी
तैयार होते हैं। मतलब अगर काम की बात है
तो ट्रस्ट बनता है। ट्रस्ट बनता है तो लोग
आपकी बात माने भी। थर्ड क्या है?
कंप्लायंस लीड टू इंफॉर्मेशन डिस्क्लोज़र।
और जब लोग बात मानने लगते हैं तो वह आपसे
खुलकर इंफॉर्मेशन शेयर भी करते हैं। अगर
मैं शॉर्ट बात में सिंपल शब्दों में बात
कहूं तो काम की बात से भरोसा बनता है।
भरोसे से बात मानी जाती है। और इस जिससे
क्या होता है? और जब भरोसा बन गया है, बात
मानी जाती है तो इसी से लोग क्या करते
हैं? अपनी सारी सच्चाई बताते हैं। इसलिए
रेलेवेंस क्रिएट ट्रस्ट, ट्रस्ट क्रिएट
कंप्लायंस, कंप्लायंस लीड टू इनेशन
डिस्क्लोज़र। नाउ टू एक्सट्रैक्ट रेलेवेंट
इनेशन यू नीड स्टंग ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस।
ऐसी इंफॉर्मेशन को निकालने के लिए हम क्या
करते हैं? किसके लिए? रेवेंस के लिए मतलब
ट्रस्ट के लिए ट्रस्ट ले लेने के लिए हम
क्या करते हैं? हम ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस
का सहारा लेते हैं। जैसे कि हम क्या करते
हैं? सोशल मीडिया इंटेलिजेंस परफॉर्म करते
हैं। हम क्या करते हैं? कंपनी के
Facebook, Twitter या जो लोकल पेजेस हैं
उनप क्या करते हैं? और या जो उनके जो
लेटेस्ट इवेंट हैशटैग है उनको चेक करते
हैं। फॉर एग्जांपल्स विजिट कंपनी ऑफिशियल
पेजेस एंड देयर लोकल कम्युनिटी। हम क्या
करते हैं? कंपनी का जो ऑफिशियल पेज है
Facebook पर, Twitter पर, Lindin पर उनको
हम विजिट करते हैं। उनकी लोकल कम्युनिटी
पेजेस को विजिट करते हैं। उनकी जो रिसेंट
पोस्ट हैं उनको देखते हैं। उनके अपडेट्स
को देखते हैं। कोई अनाउंसमेंट है तो उसको
उस पे ध्यान देते हैं। या हम क्या करते
हैं? कंपनी से रिलेवेंट जो हैशटग्स हैं या
जो भी इवेंट हुए हैं कोई कैंपेन चल रहा था
या कोई क्राइसिस सिचुएशन आई थी तो उससे
रिलेटेड हम हैशटग को फाइंड आउट करते हैं
और हैशटग से हम उस इंफॉर्मेशन को निकालने
की कोशिश करते हैं गैदर करने की कोशिश
करते हैं। दूसरी चीज हम क्या करते हैं?
लोकल न्यूज़ एंड फिजिकल एनवायरमेंट। हम
क्या करते हैं कि कंपनी जहां पर कंपनी है
वहां का जो लोकल न्यूज़पेपर्स है उसको
पढ़ते हैं। जो फ्लायर्स है, बैनर्स हैं
मतलब रीड लोकल रीड लोकल न्यूज़पेपर्स फॉर
रिसेंट इंसिडेंट इवेंट्स फेस्टिवल्स एंड
अलर्ट्स। हम क्या करते हैं? वहां का जो
लोकल न्यूज़पेपर्स हैं वो पढ़ते हैं और
खास करके हम उस इंफॉर्मेशन पर ध्यान देते
हैं जो उस कंपनी से रिलेटेड है। हम जो
बैनर्स हैं जो होर्डिंग्स लगी हुई हैं जो
फ्लायर्स लगे हुए हैं पोस्टर्स लगे हुए
हैं ऑफिस ब्रांचेज के पास उन पर ध्यान
देते हैं। उसके बाद आइडेंटिफाई डिरप्शन
रोड क्लोजर्स या इमरजेंसीज इन देयर और
जहां पर वो कंपनी है उसके आसपास क्या-क्या
चीजें हैं जो डिस्टर्ब कर सकती हैं। कहां
पर रोड बंद है, रोड है या कोई इमरजेंसी
सिचुएशंस जो आप यूज कर सकते हो। सारी
चीजों पर आप क्या करते हो? ध्यान देते हो
आप ड्यूरिंग ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस। उसके
बाद आप क्या करते हो? नेक्स्ट आपका काम
होता है कॉमन इंटरेस्ट एंड ह्यूमन
कनेक्शंस। मतलब फाइंड व्हाट कनेक्ट विद
देम? मतलब आप क्या करते हो? उनके अंदर कुछ
कॉमन इंटरेस्ट ढूंढने की कोशिश करते हो।
फॉर एग्जांपल्स डू एंप्लॉय एंजॉय हकिंग और
आउटडोर एक्टिविटीज? क्या उनके एंप्लाइजज़
को हकिंग पसंद है? डू दे पार्टिसिपेट इन
इवेंट्स लाइक स्पार्टन रेस या टग मर्डर्स
या कोई किसी इवेंट में उसके एम्प्लाइज
पार्टिसिपेट करते हैं या फिर डस द कंपनी
हैव ए बॉलिंग या सॉफ्टबॉल और फुटबॉल
फुटबॉल टीम क्या कंपनी के पास कोई कोई खुद
की कोई बॉलिंग मतलब एंटरटेनमेंट के लिए
कोई बॉलिंग या सॉफ्टबॉल टीम है या कोई
फुटबॉल टीम है अगर है तो वि लॉज़ मतलब कौन
सा वह लॉज़ यूज़ करते हैं कहां खेलते हैं
ओके और कहां कहां से चीजें वो खरीदते हैं
वो सारी चीजें आप क्या करते हो? फाइंड आउट
करने की कोशिश करते हो। अब यह सारी
इंफॉर्मेशन आ गई आपके पास। ठीक है? इससे
क्या करते हो? आप एक स्ट्रांग ओपन सोर्स
इंटेलिजेंस परफॉर्म करते हो। सो क्योंकि
इसी इंफॉर्मेशन के बेसिस पर आपका क्या
बनता है? प्रिटेक्स्ट बनता है। नेक्स्ट हम
बात करते हैं ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस डाटा
टू प्रीटेक्स्ट मैपिंग।
अब
ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस से जो डाटा आपको
मिलता है वह तब तक बेकार है जब तक उसकी
मैपिंग आप सही से नहीं करोगे। कैसे? फॉर
एग्जांपल्स स्टेप ए में क्या हुआ? अटैकर्स
ने कंपनी की Lindin प्रोफाइल चेक की। वहां
से आइडेंटिफाई किया कि कौन-कौन सी
टेक्नोलॉजी वो यूज़ कर रहे हैं। जैसे AWS
का यूज़ कर रहे हैं, जोर का यूज़ कर रहे हैं
या, सेल्स फोर्स का यूज़ कर रहे हैं। स्टेप
बी में क्या किया उन्होंने? देन ऑन
Twitter एक्स अटैकर सो एंप्लाइजज़
पार्टिसिपेटेड इन अ लोकल मैराथन। उसके बाद
जब उन्होंने Twitter पर क्या देखा कि
कंपनी के जो एंप्लाइजज़ थे किसी लोकल
मैराथन में पार्टिसिपेट किया है। उन्होंने
वो पोस्ट शेयर की है। अब हुआ क्या यहां
पर? यहां पर आपका जो प्रीटेक्स्ट था वो
बदल गया। कैसे? नाउ अटैकर इज नॉट एन आईटी
एडमिन। अब अटैकर्स आईटी एडमिन का
प्रीटेक्स्ट नहीं यूज़ करेगा। बट ए मैराथन
इवेंट कोऑर्डिनेटर कॉलिंग और ईमेलिंग द
टारगेट हाय देयर सीम टू बी ए मिसमैच इन
योर टीशर्ट साइज एंड रजिस्ट्रेशन डिटेल्स
मतलब कि अब मुझे आईटी एडमिन बनने की जरूरत
नहीं है। अब मैं बनूंगा इवेंट कोऑर्डिनेटर
और फोन करके या ईमेल पर बोलूंगा कि आपकी
टीशर्ट का साइज या जो आपने रजिस्ट्रेशन
डिटेल्स दी थी मुझे वो मिसमैच हुई है।
प्लीज रिकंफर्म कर सकते हो। बस सिंपल
आईटीआई में मुझे बनने की जरूरत नहीं है।
स्टेप सी स्टेप सी मतलब अब हर एक कंपनी के
खुद के कुछ शॉर्ट फॉर्म्स होते हैं। कुछ
वर्ड्स होते हैं। जैसे इंटरनल पोर्टल के
कुछ शॉर्ट फॉर्म होंगे। मैनेजर्स के कुछ
निक नेम होंगे। तो आपको क्या करना है? वो
फाइंड आउट करने हैं। पता लगाना है कि कौन
से शॉर्ट फॉर्म्स का वो यूज़ करते हैं।
ताकि जब आप क्या करोगे? व्हेन दी वर्ड्स
आर यूज्ड इन द प्रीक्स्ट आफ्टर गैदरिंग
वाया ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस द टारगेट
रिमेनिंग सस्पिशियंस आल्सो डिसएपीयर जब आप
क्या करते हो जो उनकी जो शॉर्ट फॉर्म्स
होती हैं जिसमें वो ज्यादातर बात करते हैं
अगर उनको आप अपने प्रीटेक्स्ट में यूज़
करोगे उससे क्या होगा आपका जो प्रिटेक्स्ट
है और भी ज्यादा स्ट्रांग हो जाएगा आपके
जो शक करने के जो चांसेस थे एंप्लाइजज़ के
वो और भी कम हो जाएंगे। उसके चांसेस और भी
लो हो जाएंगे। व्हेन यू डिज़ अटैक्स दीज़
डीप योर फिशिंग अटैक इज़ नो लगर ए कॉमन
अटैक। जब आप इतना डीप जाकर अटैक डिजाइन
करते हो। मतलब इस तरीके से आप क्या करते
हो? आपको जो रॉ डाटा मिला था आपने जो
इंफॉर्मेशन कलेक्ट की थी ओपन सोर्स
इंटेलिजेंस से आप उसको ऐसे स्टेप बाय
स्टेप मैप करते हो। मैप करते हो इसका मतलब
क्या है? कि आप एक कॉमन अटैक नहीं रहा। वो
वो अटैक बन गया एक नेशन स्टेट लेवल थ्रेट।
ठीक है? मतलब आपने उस अटैक को इतना बड़ा
अटैक में कन्वर्ट कर लिया है जो आप अपनी
रिपोर्ट में लिखोगे। ओके? जो आप अपनी एक
रिपोर्ट में लिखोगे। अब बात करते हैं एज ए
एथ एज ए एथिकल हैकर।
अब एक एथिकल हैकर के रूप में आपको यह भी
पता होना चाहिए कि टेक्निकल मैनपुलेशन को
रोका कैसे जाता है। मतलब यह था अटैक करने
की बात। अब आपको यह भी तो पता होना चाहिए
कि उसको रोक कैसे सकते हैं। उसका डिफेंड
डिफेंसिव साइड भी आपको पता होना चाहिए।
बिकॉज़ ऑर्गेनाइजेशनंस प्रोटेक्ट अगेंस्ट
दिस बाय मैनपुलेटिंग जीरो ट्रस्ट
आर्किटेक्चर एंड स्ट्रिक्ट वेरिफिकेशन
प्रोटोकॉल्स। ऑर्गेनाइजेशनंस क्या करती
हैं? इससे बचने के लिए वो जीरो ट्रस्ट
आर्किटेक्चर का यूज करती हैं। एंड
वेरिफिकेशन स्ट्रिक्ट वेरिफिकेशन
प्रोटोकॉल का यूज करती हैं। बिकॉज़ फॉर
एग्जांपल्स आप देखते हैं इफ समवन कॉल्स
क्लेमिंग टू बी एन एडमिन द रूल इज हैंग अप
एंड कॉल बैक ऑन द ऑफिशियल इंटरनल
डायरेक्टरी नंबर। मतलब
उनको बोला गया प्रोटो वेरिफिकेशन
प्रोटोकॉल के अंदर और उनको बताया गया है
ट्रेनिंग में कि अगर कोई आपको कॉल करता है
और यह बोलता है कि मैं आईटी एडमिन बात कर
रहा हूं यह बात कर रहा हूं तो सेम टाइम
फोन को कट करो और उनका जो ऑफिशियल
डायरेक्टरी नंबर है ऑफिशियल नंबर्स है उस
पे कॉल करो इससे क्या होगा कोई भी
अनवेरिफाइड सोर्स आप तक पहुंच ही नहीं
पाएगा ऊपर से आप क्या कर रहे हो आप उस
कंपनी में खुद से कॉल कर रहे हो। उस नंबर
पर खुद से कॉल कर रहे हो जिसने टैक्स
प्रेजेंट कर रहे हो। जिससे क्या होगा?
पुष्टि हो जाएगी कि सामने वाला फेक है या
सच बोल रहा है। अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन?
अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन?
यहां तक सबको समझ में आ गया?
बाकी लोग बताइए
सबको समझ में आया?
ओनली एक ही स्टूडेंट को समझ में आया बाकी
लोग यस या नो प्लीज आंसर मी
बाकी लोग नहीं आंसर करने वाले हैं। इट्स
ओके नाउ अभी हम बात करते हैं
प्रेजेंटिंग सिनेरियोस एंड टाइमिंग
टेक्निक्स। मतलब
मतलब यह है जब आप सारी इंफॉर्मेशन निकालो।
वंस यू गैदर ऑल द इंफॉर्मेशन प्रिपेयर
थ्री टू फाइव बैच सिनेरियोस एंड प्रेजेंट
देम टू द क्लाइंट प्रेजेंट देम टू द
क्लाइंट मतलब आपको क्या करना है जब आपने
सारी इंफॉर्मेशन निकाल ली आपने प्री
टेक्स्ट रेडी कर लिया तो आपको तीन से पांच
या 10 बेस्ट सिनेरियो तैयार करने हैं
तैयार करने के बाद आपको क्लाइंट के सामने
रखना है और उनसे बोलना है चूज़ करो एंड लेट
द क्लाइंट चूज़ द प्रिटेक्स्ट दे वांट टू
टेस्ट। आपको क्या करना है कि उनको बोलना
है क्लाइंट को कि इनमें से कोई एक दो जो
सिनेरियो आप चाहते हो वो चूज़ करो
टेस्ट करवाने के लिए। अब यहां पर आपके मन
में एक सवाल होगा बस सर ऐसा करने से तो
आपकी पेन टेस्टिंग फेल हो जाएगी। तो उसका
भी मैं आपको जवाब देता हूं।
ठीक है? बिल्कुल फेल हो सकती है। बट ये
आपको करना पड़ेगा। तो जब आप क्या करते हो?
तीन से पांच 10 सिनेरियो उसके सामने रखते
हो तो क्लाइंट उनमें से कोई एक सिनेरियो
चूज़ करता है। देन उसके बाद आपको क्या करना
है? कंफर्म द अटैक टाइम फ्रेम विद द
क्लाइंट। फॉर एग्जांपल समथिंग दिस वीक बट
डू नॉट शेयर द एग्जैक्ट टाइम। दिस कीप
पीपल अलर्ट व्हाइल गिविंग यू द एलिमेंट ऑफ़
सरप्राइज। मतलब यह है कि आप क्लाइंट से
अटैक का टाइम फ्रेम कंफर्म करना है कि कब
आप अटैक करना है। फॉर एग्जांपल कि जैसे इस
हफ्ते में हम कभी भी अटैक कर कर सकते हैं
या टाइम फ्रेम कंफर्म करना है। क्लाइंट
बोलता है ओके कर सकते हो तो इट्स ओके बट
आपको एग्जैक्ट टाइम नहीं बताने कि हम मंडे
को करेंगे वेडनेसडे को फ्राइडे को सैटरडे
को ऐसा नहीं बताना आपको बिकॉज़ इससे क्या
फायदा होगा? इससे कंपनी के लोग भी अलर्ट
रहेंगे और आपका एलिमेंट ऑफ सरप्राइज भी
नहीं टूटेगा। आपका एलिमेंट्स ऑफ सरप्राइज
भी बचा रहेगा। मतलब मैंने आपको क्या
बताया? आपको सिनेरियो को प्रेजेंट करना
है। उसके बाद टाइमिंग टैिक्स मतलब आपको
टाइम फ्रेम उनसे डिसाइड करवाना है कि भैया
हम नेक्स्ट 10 दिन में या इस नेक्स्ट
अपकमिंग वीक में हम यह क्या करने वाले
हैं? लाइव जाने वाले हैं। इसको हम टेस्ट
करने वाले हैं कम क्लाइंट के ऊपर। बट
एग्जैक्ट नहीं बताना। बट हम करने वाले हैं
इस वीक में। इसमें क्या है? एक तो जो
क्लाइंट की टीम है अलर्ट है बट आपका
एलिमेंट ऑफ़ सरप्राइज आपकी कैपेबिलिटी
दोनों ही चीज़ हैं। उसके बाद मैं आपको बात
करता हूं एक रियल वर्ल्ड चैलेंज की। इन
रियल वर्ल्ड चैलेंज एवरीथिंग इज नॉट
परफेक्ट। रियल वर्ल्ड में हमेशा सब कुछ
परफेक्ट नहीं होता। कई बार क्या होता है?
क्लाइंट समटाइ्स लीक द प्रीक्स्ट और फिक्स
द टाइमिंग एंड मेकिंग एंप्लई अलर्ट एंड
टेस्ट फेल। अब कई बार क्लाइंट क्या करता
है कि वह अपने एंप्लई को पहले ही आपका
प्रीक्स्ट था। आप उन्होंने डिसाइड कर लिया
और वह प्रीक्स्ट लीक कर देता है अपने
एंप्लई के बीच में कि ऐसे-से वो करने वाले
हैं। ऐसा-सा टेस्ट होने वाला है। बी अलर्ट
हमारा कोई भी एक बंदा उसमें नहीं फंसना
चाहिए। फिर
या फिर हम क्या दूसरी क्या चीज क्या करते
हैं? वो टेस्टर को बोलते हैं कि ठीक है
तुम एक काम करना
दो ठीक दोपहर 2:00 बजे ईमेल भेजना या कॉल
करोगे। सेंड ईमेल और कॉल एट 2 पी.m. साहब।
मतलब आप ये टेस्ट करने के लिए इस टाइम पे
करना। टाइम फ्रेम डिसाइड करवा दिया। सब
कुछ बता दिया। ठीक है? इससे क्या हुआ? और
एंप्लई अलर्ट रहते हैं और आपका टेस्ट फेल
हो गया। अब देखो ऐसा करने से आपका कुछ
नहीं गया। नथिंग आपका कुछ भी नहीं गया।
वैसे-सा करने से अगर कोई कंपनी ऐसा करवाती
भी है तो ऐसा करने से आपका कुछ नहीं होने
वाला। क्योंकि अटैक जब होता है रियल अटैक
वो बता के नहीं होता। वह क्या है कि आज तो
अपने एंप्लई को बचा लेंगे
कि यह चीज करके बट हर रोज नहीं बचा
पाएंगे। टेस्टिंग से बचा लेंगे बट रियल
अटैक से नहीं बचा पाएंगे। ठीक है? चलो
इसका भी एक एग्जांपल समझाता हूं मैं आपको
कि एक रियल स्टोरी है। एक रियल रियल केस
है। व्हेन ए स्ट्रिक्ट टाइम विंडो टर्न
इंटू ए लूप होल फॉर सक्सेस। मतलब अभी मैं
आपको एक ऐसा केस शेयर करने वाला हूं। ठीक
है? यह
केस है कि एक्चुअल में हुआ है ऐसा ऐसा
नहीं अपने पास से मैंने बनाया यह केस
एक्चुअल में हुआ है। द क्लाइंट गिव द
टेस्टिंग टीम ए स्ट्रिक्ट टाइम विंडो एंड
सेड यू कैन कॉल ओनली ड्यूरिंग दिस टाइम कि
क्लाइंट ने टेस्टिंग टीम को एक स्ट्रिक्ट
टाइम विंडो दे दी और बोला कि तुम इस टाइम
पर ही इस टाइम पर कॉल कर सकते हो। उसने
बोला किसने? क्लाइंट क्लाइंट ने। देन
कॉन्ट्रैक्ट केविएट मतलब लूप हो।
कॉन्ट्रैक्ट में लूप होल क्या था? वो था
इफ एनी एंप्लई रिक्वेस्ट ए कॉल बैक द
टेस्टर कैन कॉल देम अगेन एनी टाइम विदाउट
नीडिंग परमिशंस। मतलब कि कॉन्ट्रैक्ट में
एक छोटा सा लूप होल था। यह लूप होल उनको
नहीं पता था। हमें पता है बिकॉज़ वी आर अ
टेस्टर्स। तो कॉन्ट्रैक्ट में लूप होल
क्या था? एक शर्त थी। उन्होंने अपनी तरफ
से शर्त रखी थी क्लाइंट ने। बट वो हमारे
लिए लूप होल बन गया। उन्होंने शर्त रखी थी
कि अगर किसी एंप्लई ने खुद कॉल बैक करने
को बोला तो टेस्टर उन्हें किसी भी टाइम
बिना किसी कंसेंट के बिना किसी परमिशन के
दोबारा कॉल कर सकता है। और टेस्टर ने क्या
किया? टेस्टर ने इसी लूपॉल का बहुत खतरनाक
यूज़ किया। कैसे? मतलब
क्लाइंट ने बोला था उसको कि
दे कैन कॉल ओनली विद इन मतलब उनका गोल था
इस टाइम फ्रेम में टेस्टिंग करनी है। तो
चलो भैया बात आती है अब टेस्टर की। टेस्टर
ने क्या किया? टेस्टर कॉल्स विद इन द
अलाउड टाइम एंड क्रिएट लाउड नॉइज़ एंड फेक
इंटरप्शनंस टू मेक कॉल क्वालिटी पुअर।
मतलब जो अटैकर था या टेस्टर था। टेस्टर ने
डेजिग्नेटेड टाइम पर कॉल किया। जो कंपनी
ने बोला था उसी टाइम पे कॉल किया और
टेस्टर ने क्या किया अपने बैकग्राउंड में
बहुत ज़्यादा नॉइज़ क्रिएट किया। मतलब इट
क्रिएट्स ए फेक एंड फेक नॉइज़ एंड फेक
डिसेप्शन टू मेक टू एंड थर्ड पर्सन। मतलब
इसका मतलब क्या है कि उन्होंने इतना
ज्यादा नॉइज़ क्रिएट किया कि
ऐसा लगे सामने वाली पार्टी को कि नेटवर्क
इशू है ऐसी एक्टिंग की कि बहुत ज्यादा शोर
है, बहुत ज्यादा बैकग्राउंड नॉइस है। कुछ
नेटवर्क इशू है। सो इसे सुनाई नहीं दे
रहा। अब इससे हुआ क्या? नॉइज़ एंड फेक
डिसेप्शन मेक टू एंड थर्ड ऑफ द एंप्लॉय से
प्लीज कॉल मी बैक लेटर। अब उन्होंने जब
ऐसी एक्टिंग की कि नेटवर्क इशू है, यह है
वो है मतलब कि इतना ज्यादा नॉइज़ क्रिएट कर
दिया जानबूझकर उन्होंने नेटवर्क इशू शो
किया तो एंप्लॉय ने फोन कट किया और दो
तिहाई लोगों ने खुद बोला कि अरे आपकी आवाज
नहीं आ रही। आप मुझे बाद में कॉल कर लेना।
ठीक है? उन्होंने बाद में कॉल कर लेना। यह
एंप्लई ने खुद बोला। एंड उसके बाद बात
करते हैं कॉल बैक विंडो।
दे आस्क फॉर ए कॉल बैक आउटसाइड द लाउड
हाउस विंडो क्योंकि लूप होल यहीं पर था कि
एमंप्लई ने खुद से बोला है कि आप मुझे बाद
में कॉल कर लेना और यह आपके कॉन्ट्रैक्ट
में लूप होल है। तो अभी हुआ क्या? अब अटैक
की क्रोनोलॉजी है यह कि अटैक कैसे किया?
अब यह हैकर्स का माइंड कैसे काम किया?
इसको समझने की कोशिश करो। हैकर ने क्या
किया? उन्हें
कॉल कब किया?
उन्होंने कॉल तब किया जो डेेजिग्नेटेड
विंडो थी उसके बाहर मतलब जो टाइम फ्रेम
डिसाइड हुआ था कि इस टाइम फ्रेम में कॉल
करना उसके बाहर उन्होंने बाद में कॉल किया
और उन्हें उस वक्त कॉल किया जब जो एंप्लॉय
थे उनका गार्ड डाउन था वो क्या थे रिलैक्स
थे कि टेस्टिंग खत्म हो चुकी है।
एंप्लाइजज़ आर रिलैक्स थिंकिंग द टेस्ट
टाइम इज ओवर। मतलब एंप्लई सोच रहे थे
टेस्टिंग खत्म हो चुकी है भैया। तो अभी वह
बिल्कुल बेफिक्र होकर रिलैक्स कर रहे थे
क्योंकि कंपनी ने तो बता दिया एमंप्लई को
कि भैया इस टाइम पर टेस्टिंग करनी है और
एंप्लई को बता दिया कोई फंसना नहीं चाहिए
लेकिन शर्त में रखी शर्त में था लूप होल
अब हैकर था हैकर ने लूप होल का फायदा
उठाया लूप होल का फायदा उठा के कि एंप्लई
ने खुद से बोला और एंप्लॉय को उस टाइम पे
कॉल किया जिस टाइम पर हैक उसको एंप्लॉय को
लग रहा था कि अब कुछ हो गया है हम बच गए
अब कुछ नहीं होने वाला उस टाइम पे कॉल
उन्होंने किया कॉल किया और उससे हुआ क्या
है? एम्प्लाइज अननोइंगली शेयर द सेंसिटिव
इनेशन विद द टेस्टर। और उन्होंने एंप्लई
ने बिना सोचे समझे सारी सेंसिटिव
इंफॉर्मेशन टेस्टर को दे दी। और सारी
इंफॉर्मेशन किसको दे दी? टेस्टर को दे दी।
तो दिस इज कॉल्ड हैकर्स माइंड। इसी को
बोलते हैं हैकर माइंड। मतलब
समझ में आया कि यह उसका इलाज है कि कुछ
लोग क्या बोलते हैं कि नहीं हमने आपके लिए
टाइम फ्रेम डिसाइड करते हैं। उसी टाइम पे
आपको टेस्टिंग करनी है। कॉन्ट्रैक्ट साइन
हो रखा है। तो फिर आपको
कॉन्ट्रैक्ट के अंदर लूप होल भी पता होना
चाहिए। यह भी पता होना चाहिए कि इस
कॉन्ट्रैक्ट में लूप होल कहां पर है।
कमियां कहां पर है। मैं उसका कैसे फायदा
उठा सकता हूं। बिकॉज़ हमसे स्मार्ट तो नहीं
होंगे क्लाइंट। अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन?
क्योंकि हम रोज पेन टेस्टिंग करेंगे।
इसीलिए हमें पता है कहां, क्या, कैसे कब।
तो यह एक रियल केस समझ में आया? अंडरस्टुड
एवरीवन? यहां तक?
तो, आज के लेक्चर की समरी क्या है? कि
ऑब्जेक्टिव और मेथड पहले ही क्लियर कर
लेने चाहिए। बिफोर एग्जीक्यूटिंग एनी
टेस्ट। अटैक्स, ऑब्जेक्टिव और मेथड शुड बी
क्लियरली डिफाइंड। दे इंश्योर ए फोकस्ड
एंड मेजरेबल्स एंड इफेक्टिव अटैक
मतलब उससे आपका अटैक और आपकी टेस्टिंग
बेहतर हो जाती है। दूसरा बात करें
दूसरी बात करें मैं आपको समझाता हूं। ओके
दूसरी बात करें द मोर यू प्रोटेक्स्ट इज
कनेक्टेड द लोकल मतलब इसका मतलब क्या है?
हमारा प्रीटेक्स्ट जितना लोकल और करंट
इवेंट से जुड़ा रहेगा। मतलब आपने जो
प्रीक्स्ट बनाया है उनको फंसाने के लिए वह
जितना रियलिस्टिक होगा जितना करंट इवेंट्स
जितने उसमें लोकल चीजें ऐड होंगी उतना ही
ज्यादा वो स्ट्रांग होगा आपका। उसके बाद
बात किए हैं कॉन्ट्रैक्ट लूप फॉल्स आर नॉट
मिस्टेक्स दे आर अपॉर्चुनिटीज। एज एन
एथिकल हैकर नोइंग हाउ टू लिगली और
स्मार्टली यूज़ देम कैन गिव यू द अपर
हैंड। ठीक है?
अब कॉन्ट्रैक्ट के लूप होल एज एन एथिकल
हैकर
आपको अपने फायदे के लिए कैसे यूज करने हैं
वह आपको पता होना चाहिए क्योंकि जो
कॉन्ट्रैक्ट में अगर लूप होल्स हैं वह
गलतियां नहीं है वह आपके लिए अपॉर्चुनिटीज
हैं और एज एथिकल एथिकल हैकर्स उनको लीगली
और स्मार्ट वे से आपको कैसे यूज़ करना है
वह आपको आना चाहिए आपको आना चाहिए इसलिए
अंडरस्टैंडिंग पीपल टाइम टाइमिंग लूप होल
साइकोलॉजी व्हेन कंबाइंड एथिकली क्रिएट
हाई इंपैक्ट रिजल्ट जब सारी चीजें जब आप
लोगों को समझते हो उनकी साइकोलॉजी समझते
हो उनकी टाइमिंग समझते हो उनकी केमिया
समझते हो साइकोलॉजी समझते हो और इन सब
चीजों को जब मिला के आप सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
अटैक करते हो तब उसका जो इंपैक्ट होता है
काफी हाई इंपैक्ट होता है। अभी उन्होंने
पूछा था फिनक कौन ने कि एक बार और समझाओ।
यह कहानी ऐसी है कि
एक क्लाइंट ने एक पेंटेस्टर को एक
कॉन्ट्रैक्ट दिया कि आपको क्या करना है?
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग करनी है। और उन्होंने
क्या किया लिया? जब उन्होंने बोला ना
सिनेरियो प्रेजेंट किया। एक सिनेरियो
प्रेजेंट किया। सिनेरियो चूज़ कर लिया
क्लाइंट ने कि आपको यह सिनेरियो क्या करना
है?
इस पर्टिकुलर टाइम फ्रेम में फॉर
एग्जांपल्स आप ले सकते हो कि आपको दिन में
2:00 बजे ही 2 pm 2:00 बजे ही आपको क्या
करना है? कॉल करना है। आपको फ्रीजिंग ईमेल
भेजनी है। उस टाइम पे आप क्या कर सकते हो?
टेस्टिंग कर सकते हो। बोला आप इसी में
करनी है। आपको इसके अलावा आपको अलाउड नहीं
है। तो ऐसा बोला क्लाइंट ने और यह
कॉन्ट्रैक्ट बना के दे दिया। तो यह तो दे
दिया टेस्टिंग टीम को। अब उन्होंने एक
शर्त रखी। शर्त क्या रखी थी? शर्त रखी कि
अगर किसी एंप्लई ने खुद से यह बोला कि
बोला कि बाद में कॉल करना कॉल बैक करने को
बोला कि एंप्लई ने खुद से बोला कि आप मुझे
बाद में कॉल करना हम बाद में बात करेंगे।
अगर ऐसा बोला किसी भी एंप्लई ने तो आप बाद
में जब कॉल करोगे उसके लिए आपको किसी भी
परमिशन की जरूरत नहीं है। आप बिना किसी
कंसेंट के बिना किसी परमिशंस के उसको
डायरेक्टली कॉल कर सकते हो। यह
कॉन्ट्रैक्ट में लिखा हुआ था। यह शर्त थी।
अब इसमें लूप होल क्या था? अटैकर ने क्या
किया? उसी टाइम फ्रेम में कॉल किया। जब
उसने कॉल किया, उसने ऐसे सिनेरियो सेटअप
किया कि बैकग्राउंड में बहुत सारा नॉलेज
क्रिएट किया। उसने ऐसे जताया एंप्लई के
सामने कि नेटवर्क इशू है। उसने क्या किया?
नेटवर्क इशू है।
ठीक है? नेटवर्क इशू है। अब जब नेटवर्क
इशू लगेगा तो एंप्लई ने बोला कि आप मेरे
को बाद में कॉल बैक करना। कांटेक्ट में यह
बोला था अगर एंप्लई ने बोला है कि मुझे
कॉल बैक करना तो आप बिना किसी कंसेंट के
उस एंप्लई को कॉल कर सकते हो। और आपने
क्या किया? जानबूझकर इतना फेक डिस्टरप्शन
क्रिएट किया कॉल के अंदर इतना फेक नॉइज़
क्रिएट किया कि एंप्लई ने खुद से बोला कि
भाई आपकी आवाज नहीं आ रही। साफ-साफ मुझे
कुछ सुनाई नहीं दे रहा। प्लीज आप मुझे बाद
में कॉल कर सकते हो। आपसे परेशान हो के
बोल दिया। और ऐसे कितने थे? ऐसे दो तिहाई
लोग थे जिन्होंने क्या बोला कि बाद में
कॉल करना। अब कांटेक्ट में क्या लिखा था?
अगर एंप्लॉय ने ऐसा बोला बाद में कॉल
करना। तो आप आपको कोई परमिशन की जरूरत
नहीं है। आप कॉल कर सकते हो। तो ठीक है।
अब फॉर एग्जांपल टेस्टिंग टाइम रखा था 2
से लेके 5 के बीच में। आप कभी भी कॉल कर
सकते हो। मतलब इसमें ही टेस्टिंग करनी है
या आप सुबह मॉर्निंग से ले शाम तक
टेस्टिंग करनी है। अब एंप्लई ने भी क्या
किया? उसने अटैकर्स ने टेस्टिंग टाइम खत्म
हो गया। एम एंप्लई रिलैक्स मोड में चला
गया। बोला ओके। क्योंकि उसको बताया गया था
उसके बॉस के द्वारा कि भैया इतने टाइम से
टाइम में टाइम फ्रेम में टेस्टिंग होगी।
यह उनका प्रीक्स्ट है। फोन उठाए तो ऐसा
करना है आपको। फोन नहीं उठाना। रिप्लाई
नहीं करना, वो नहीं करना। अब अटैकर तो
स्मार्ट था। तो उसने क्या किया? जब कॉल
बैक कब की? जब वो रिलैक्स हो गए। उन्हें
सोचा कि टेस्टिंग कंप्लीट हो चुकी है। मैं
नहीं फंसा और हम बच गए। उस टाइम पे कॉल
करते ही अपुन के गार्ड डाउन थे। मतलब सोच
ही नहीं रहे थे। रिलैक्स थे। तो उस टाइम
पे अननोइंगली उन सारे एंप्लई ने क्या कर
दी? सारी सेंसिटिव इन शेयर कर दी टेस्टर
के साथ। क्योंकि टेस्टर ने जानबूझकर वह
नॉइज़ क्रिएट किया था। जानबूझकर ऐसा जताया
था कि मुझे हमें सुनाई नहीं दे रहा। कुछ
नेटवर्क इशू हो रहा है। अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन?
समझ में आई?
अगर आपका कोई सवाल है, कोई डाउट है तो
मुझसे पूछ सकते हो।
ब्रो इसमें मैं बोल रहा हूं कि आपने सुनो
मैं आपके उस पर आता हूं चैटिंग पर आप
मुझसे बोल रहे हो कि या चलो
चैट ओके
कि हाउ डिड अटैकर्स नो अबाउट दिस सिनेरियो
बिकॉज़ इट वाज़ अ टेस्टर हु वाज डूइंग दिस
वर्क अटैकर्स की बात अटैकर्स और टेस्टर एक
ही है यहां पर मैं जो अटैकर्स और टेस्टर
यूज कर रहा हूं मैं टेस्टर को ही अटैकर
बोल रहा हूं
ठीक है? अटैक टेस्टर ने ही किया है। टेस्ट
करने वाले ने। वह एक ही है। सेम ही है।
अंडरस्टुड?
समझ में आ गया?
तो किसी को कोई डाउट है क्लास से रिलेटेड?
आज के सेशन में मजा आया सबको?
कुछ सीखने को मिला?
कुछ सीखने को मिला? कुछ भी और जल्दी आपके
लिए मैं एक बहुत ज्यादा इंटरेस्टिंग बोल
सकते हो। कुछ लेके आने वाला हूं इन द सेंस
कि जो चीजें
कुछ रियल केस स्टडीज आई एम प्लानिंग फॉर
दैट। इस क्लास का हिस्सा नहीं होंगे वे।
बट मैं आप लोगों से रिक्वेस्ट करूंगा उसको
देखना जरूर सुनना जरूर और आना जरूर उसमें
ऐसी चीजें डिस्कस करेंगे जो उसमें किसी ने
नहीं किया हो
ओके यू आर वाचिंग लास्ट वीडियो माय सीरीज
गुड
तो किसी को कोई डाउट है?
अगर आपको कभी कोई डाउट भी होता है तो
प्लीज कमेंट बॉक्स में पूछ सकते हो। वहां
पर आपको रिप्लाई मिलेगा।
चलिए फिर कोई डाउट नहीं है किसी का तो हम
सेशन को एंड करें। बताओ।
ओके थैंक यू तो मुझे बोलना चाहिए कि आप
लोग आते हो समय निकाल के क्लासेस को अटेंड
करते हो और आपके लिए अगर बेनिफिशियल है तो
मेरी तो रिक्वेस्ट आप लोगों से इतनी ही है
प्लीज प्लीज प्लीज शेयर इट इसको शेयर
कीजिए बाकी लोगों के साथ ताकि उनको को भी
सीखने को मिले।
चलिए फिर अगर आपका कोई भी डाउट नहीं है तो
सेशन को एंड करते हैं और नेक्स्ट वीक
मिलते हैं सैटरडे और संडे को अपने नए
टॉपिक के साथ, नई क्लासेस के साथ। तब तक
के लिए आप क्या कर सकते हो? प्रीवियस
क्लासेस का रिवीजन कर सकते हो, देख सकते
हो या आपने फर्स्ट टाइम हमारी क्लासेस में
आए हो। फर्स्ट टाइम आप डीएचई की सीरीज में
आए हो तो आप क्या कर सकते हो? स्टार्टिंग
से मंडे टू फ्राइडे के बीच में अगर आपके
पास समय है, टाइम है तो आप क्या कर सकते
हो? उन क्लासेस को देख सकते हो, कवर कर
सकते हो। बिकॉज़ आपको मैं एक चीज बता देता
हूं क्योंकि यह एक सर्टिफिकेशन बनने वाला
है जिसका एक एग्जाम भी होगा और एक प्रॉपर
सर्टिफिकेट भी मिलेगा और इसका एग्जाम जल्द
ही डिसाइड होने वाला है। ओके? तो
तब तक के लिए बाय-ब एंड टेक केयर टेक केयर
एंड गुड नाइट एवरीवन।